père et du fils et du saint-esprit une
bénédiction particulière du produit de
la terre et du travail des hommes
le 22 janvier c'est la saint vincent le
patron des vignerons dans le sancerrois
c'était jour de fête à chavignol ils
étaient plus de 200 à participer à cet
hommage des célébrations qui vont durer
jusqu'au 2 février dans les quatorze
communes viticoles du pays fort c'est
très important parce que c'est ça
représente la tradition et puis ça
arrive dans une vie ça arrive une fois
peut-être deux maintenant parce qu on
est un peu moins qu'à une époque mais
bon c'est quand même quelque chose assez
rare donc on l'attend depuis longtemps
et puis un jour la main c'est oui c'est
important mais après l'église une
procession dans les rues du village pour
enfin pouvoir goûter le nectar de
l'année qui ne trompe pas les pas les
experts le millésime donc 2019
il est c'est très bon millésime vous
allez me dire tout le monde dise à tous
les hommes et et c'est mieux que ça
parce que on a eu une année épouvantable
de chaleur on pensait pas faire du vin
ne réussit à faire un peu de vin ont
pensé qu'ils auraient pas d'acidité il
ya plus d'acidité que 2018 il ya un bon
équilibre
c'est un millésime inespéré viticulteurs
ouvriers viticoles sont tous présents
pour goûter ce nouveau millésime qui
dépasse les frontières hexagonales au
japon chaque année quand la récolte du
riz pour le sac et se terminer les
célébrations ont lieu pour honorer cette
nouvelle production et l'a dédié au dieu
des dieux qui pour encore un an brero
sur le sancerrois